so
you were talking to steven about another
project last july
and uh so i'm curious what was that
other project
that you were talking about right before
you transitioned into let's make a movie
about it
during the pandemic um
it's a i have an idea for spy franchise
you know my first time venturing back
into that world since board identity
and uh so i was talking to steve about
that
and then uh
and on that call uh
pj sandwich was on the call
um and at the end of the call pj's like
why don't we
talk about what about writing something
right now to shoot this september
because the spy thing was like for the
future sure
most pandemic
and uh and possibly for me after i go to
space i mean it was you know it was for
the future
and pj's like what about something we do
right now
um so that's you know
uh i'm actually working with a
with an actor on the uh on the spy thing
and
uh he the funny thing is like
in in october he was like you know
have you found a writer yet
and i was like well a funny thing
happened
my first conversation with a writer
about our spy idea we ended up
deciding to write a different movie and
i've now gone and shot it
he was like what i was like we we just
we came up with an idea for a different
movie and we've and he's like what have
you shot i said we
he was like that was just like yesterday
i was like i know we we came up with an
idea for a movie and we wrote it and
we've now shot it i'm done
so now i can focus back on our spy idea
he was like was that going to happen to
the next writer you talked to like i was
like no no that was like that's like a
one-off situation that's never happened
before
how easy was it for you talk a little
bit about you know sometimes getting
financing for something
can be tricky and so you guys come up
with the idea
talk a little bit about was it one of
these things where you got the financing
super fast like it was one of these
things you
how did that come together yeah because
you know so i was
talking about the insurance of it all
like i was you know the idea was we were
going to try to
shoot a movie go go go to really into
uncharted waters
uh there were no independent films going
into production in england
you know there was there's no way to get
insurance it's like
it there's no way to guarantee you can
finish the movie which is the biggest
risk
somebody makes when they finance a movie
is it's not
what if the movie's not good the biggest
risk is what if the movie isn't
completed
and you normally get things called
completion bonds you know
none of that was going to be possible so
when we were i said when we approach a
financier
we're gonna have to make this attractive
enough to them
that they're willing to take a chance
that
that the gamble's worth it which means
shooting it at a low enough budget that
if the film is not able to be completed
it was worth the risk because
on the flip side if we do complete it
the reward would be enough
so that that was from my my conception
from the beginning was that we needed to
do this
um really uh
um we need to keep the budget down
because of the pandemic
i said we need to shoot this quickly
because every week that we're shooting
runs the risk of somebody getting sick
and the production being shut down
uh and so in which
luckily shooting quickly also brings the
budget down so at least everything was
sort of pointing in one direction which
is
the the only shot we had to get locked
down
financed and the best shot we had to be
able to finish shooting the movie
completed would be to shoot it very
quickly
and i really was interested in
you know i've my films reflect
the environments in which they were shot
there's other filmmakers who just
totally control the environment it
doesn't matter what's happening in the
world i i
i allow the real world to seep into my
movies
so the shaky camera work of born
identity
was not a creative choice that
that really happened because matt and i
were sneaking into the garden gardenerd
to shoot something without a permit and
which i had been doing on my independent
films prior to that but the problem is
matt damon
was recognizable so it was hard to sneak
around the garden
nord with matt damon and so we kept
having to move quickly before people
recognized him
and that's why all that shaky camera
work is because it was just no time
to to set up a shot and it became part
of the style not only of the movie but
of
of the whole franchise um so
i you know experiences like that you
know
have of allowing you know what's
happening on the set
to sort of infuse the actual
footage infused into the footage you
know has become
you know part of my style of filmmaking
i said you know lockdown should be no
different
it's we're shooting this movie during a
pandemic
whatever that does to the production i'm
going to let that appear on screen too
it will affect it so in this case to
uh because of uh
because of the budget requirements
because london was going to be shutting
down around us while we're shooting
said we have to shoot this as quickly as
possible
and i thought that's going to add an
interesting
tone and flavor to a movie
that for most of it is chewitel and
annie at home locked down
you know that could i have a short
attention span that could get pretty
boring pretty quickly
but not going to get boring if if it's
if it's filmed with the urgency of
uh we got to get we got to get through
this before we get shut down
end up on screen which it does there's a
there's an urgency and an energy
to lock down that
makes it you know more fun and more fun
with people
with short attention spans um and that
you you know if this same script filmed
a year from now
would shoot you know we shot in 18 days
if you shot this same script
a year from now hoping the pandemic's
over
it would be like a 45-day shoot and the
film would look different the
performances would be different
100 you mentioned obviously because of
the pandemic
uh the more people that are around the
more of a risk
that kovid can seep into the production
so when you're
shooting this uh and with the 18 day
schedule
are you purposely sort of pulling back
as
many people in terms of the behind the
scenes like how did it affect the crew
and the behind the scenes of what is
right behind the camera
are there just you know how with the
departments like you know
a fraction of what they normally are
yeah it was
uh luckily everything sort of lined up
in the same direction
um as i said like you know keeping the
budget number down and getting in and
out before there's an outbreak
both worked in the same direction
because it meant shooting
fewer days of shooting cost less money
than more days of shooting
um similarly um i wanted the crew to be
smaller
because the more people working the more
chance there could be an outbreak every
single person is
is as is a risk factor um
and in particular on on lockdown and i'd
probably
not make me look so good but i i
i used to work as a pa
and i said you know the pas are going to
be our highest risk on this movie
because you know a 24 year old pa
at the end of a long shoot day might
still go out with their friends
there's no way that i
or the dp or the cast are doing
anything other than going to sleep or
getting ready for the next day at the
end of a shoot day because we're older
um and so i i decided that we really had
to limit
the sort of entry-level jobs on the
production and so
you know each department had to each
department sort of
had fewer sort of of the entry-level
production assistant people than they
might normally have
and maybe it was unfair of me but i just
said like
you know you're gonna you're
people are not gonna have assistance on
this movie
you know on my second day when i was
like starving to death because i was
like why is nobody brought me any food
and they're like doug it's because you
said you didn't want any assistance on
set
so like if you want food you're gonna
have to go get something yourself
there's no
there are no assistance right
i actually think that probably uh i get
what you're saying because you're
probably right
you know when you're you you i anyway i
could open that door but
um you were doing one of the things that
i think is fascinating that people might
not realize is you
set out you started with a 180 page
script
i guess which is just you know you
that's just a lot
you know so talk a little bit about for
people that don't realize
180 page script sometimes can mean a
three hour movie
it always means a three-hour movie i
mean that's you know
it's a page you know a minute a page and
you know because steve was writing the
script up until basically we started
shooting
um and so we didn't know you know
chewatel if you talk to him you know
when i cast him i gave him
90 pages of the script that's all we had
and he said to me you know how how's
steve knight gonna wrap this up in 20
pages i'm really curious to see how he
pulls that off
uh and then obviously the joke was he it
took 90 pages even then i mean steve
became like one of these
you know people you because then you
know he was giving us the pages and
chunks so the next chunk of pages took
us to like page 140 and steve
swore there'd only be five more pages
and then the script ended up being about
180 pages
um and i didn't change this the schedule
right because the same concerns i told
you about about covet about the budget
meant that i wanted to shoot the movie
in 18 days
i really was thinking you know i shot
swingers in 18 days but the swinger
script was 100 pages
and i was like okay we're just going to
have to shoot twice as fast
as we thought we were going to have to
shoot and
that will be part of the style of the
movie and then
but i didn't want to make a three-hour
movie and i didn't want to
have to make choices in editing to throw
things away that i liked
because the movie was running too long
so my first step was to sort of read the
script out loud to myself
a little bit more quickly and time
myself
and i sort of got to this place where i
thought like a 40 seconds per page
pace would make wouldn't result in a
two-hour movie
and that ended up being you know my the
main instruction i gave you know
you know it would be the main
instruction i gave as
as a director on the set of this movie
was
can you just say that more quickly
sometimes followed by uh
i don't need you to act as much as
you're acting just say the words
like the words will do the job for you
like forget
forget about the dramatic pauses and and
like we just
you know you don't we don't because
actors are used to putting dramatic
pauses into scenes and i was like we
just
we don't have time for that we can we
can pick
our moments where we're going to put the
dramatic pause and it and ultimately it
makes
lockdown more fun to watch because it's
just it's just moving along at such a
breezy pace
but you know it was it was nothing annie
or chuatel had ever confronted before
and to be honest
nothing i'd ever done before i was like
but i i said this is
i we have no choice because i don't want
this movie to be three hours and i think
it'll be really fun
um and they trusted me i mean this might
be the fastest turnaround i've ever seen
in terms of
filming a movie having it premiere you
know this is
pretty incredible so uh how did you
giving a
movie to if you throw conceiving in it
it's for sure the fastest
exactly so mike my question is was there
any thought about
um about where where and when you wanted
this thing to premiere
um we knew we wanted to finish it by the
end of the year
like that was our plan that was how we
budgeted i said like this is that
everything was everything was geared
around being done by the end of the year
um we didn't know what the world would
look like at the end of the year
we didn't know if the virus would be
better or worse but we said like we
wanted you know this
film is so definitively a 2020 story we
wanted to
just shoot it in 2020 and and be done at
the end of 2020 which we did
um and then while we were editing
suddenly the conversation turned to okay
well
it's uh how do we release this you know
we started having conversations with
people who could distribute movies and
and
um yeah because we really did want to
get it out right away
and most of the buyers were like well
you know it's
we're big corporations and we we would
take you know
four to six months to come up with a
plan for putting it out
and warner brothers saw it and said
we want it immediately like how
can you finish it any faster than you're
currently planning on finishing it
which was already a crazy schedule like
to finish shooting at the end of october
and be done at christmas which was our
plan our last day of post was gonna be
december 23rd they're like
can you make it december 18. so we can
put it on the air
um in in january and
i of course said yes and you know my
producers are like what are you crazy
but i was like
everything else we've done is crazy like
and i just love the spirit
that we found a distributor
that's as insane as we are
that's willing to sort of ask for the
impossible
and we did we delivered it when you're
shooting the movie
it's an 18 day shoot when you're
starting to get to like day 15
day 16 how behind are you in the
schedule
were those last few days like oh my god
we have so much to do
we were never behind not one day
or the feeling that i got towards the
end was
because i was a little cavalier if you'd
heard me in conversations in august
you know i was raising the money for the
film i was a little cavalier i was like
look we're gonna
we're gonna set out to go make this
movie we're all taking a chance on it
that it actually could be completed
and i i would have been fairly cavalier
i'm like i i don't know if i can finish
this movie
like nobody can tell you it's finishable
because we just don't
no one's ever attempted to make an
independent film under these conditions
ever and it's
i'm gonna try i mean i'm gonna put all
of my
you know brain power into rolling with
the punches whatever
whatever happens to the world i'm gonna
but
i don't know if i can finish it i was
really blunt about that
i don't know i don't know if anybody i
don't know if it's possible to make a
movie under these conditions
but we're going to try the thing is with
each day of shooting
i was so in love with what i was getting
you know annie and chuatel were just so
amazing on screen and steve knight's
script was just they were just
bringing it to life way beyond my
wildest dream of of how
how good this movie could be and so with
each day
it became something that i was more
protective of
so the cavalier attitude in august by
the time you asked me like what it would
be like you know on day 15
on day 15 i was like trying to protect
the 14 days that had preceded it and it
was like we need to
we got we just have four more days to
get through
you know i was like please like you know
because london was shutting down around
us
that the opening shot of the movie was
you know
i shot you know on the
two or three weeks into the production i
took a camera home
and i was like i'm just gonna film the
intersection in front of my house
because
london's now empty
you know this everything was shutting
down restaurants everything
and um so i suddenly was getting
you know just i had something to protect
so i was just uh that was what the
emotion but there was
we were not behind schedule it's so
interesting because i i think about
the shots that you got like that and
if this had been filmed god willing the
pandemic ends and
if something was trying to recreate this
the cost of trying to get some of those
shots would be
so much more difficult yeah you would
end up with one or the other you'd end
up with sort of a big budget movie
or or you could end up with something
that's
quirky and small but we were able to
sort of do both because
we were we're a small character driven
movie but
you know we did have the scale of a
dessert in london
completely let me ask you uh what what
which cameras did you end up using and
why
um we use the re large format
and uh
it was my dp's choice uh
remy uh um
last time i still can't pronounce i i
end up coming you know a lot of these
dps have you know
my dp on on the wall like i never said i
ended up calling roman the russian
grammy alder for sorry but it's uh um
you know uh it was remy's choice and and
you know remy was was was a real
hero of the production because you know
to shoot
this kind of page count and and pull it
off
i mean he really
and and do it so artfully uh
he was the perfect dp and and
you know it was like i think it been a
while since he'd done a film like this
that was so
you know so outrageous i mean this 8
180 page script in 18 days is the kind
of movie that you sort of imagine
you know a couple of kids go and make
completely um in fact at some point on
the the shoot you know
one of the grueling days you know
remy turned to me and he goes do you
have any idea how old i am
and i said actually no
and then that was the end of it we just
kept going well
i wanna one of the things is you used to
be a
director of photography you shot your
early movies how when you're shooting
something like lockdown where you have
to do 14
15 scenes a day sometimes
talk a little bit about how you pick
camera placement
for these scenes when you are just
rushing through everything how much
debate
is there we're gonna put the camera here
or we this is the better shot
um yeah you you rehearsed the scene i
mean it wasn't it was no different than
other movies other than you
uh you gotta really think quick on your
feet and i was like again i was like
let's embrace that we're gonna go with
our gut instinct we would do one
blocking of the scene and and
um i would i i or may be like i think we
should i think our
our hero angle should be here and
we just went with it like it was you
know that
when i work with tom cruise you know
there's there's more
we we have more money and more time and
so in that kind of environment
tom and i like to rehearse the night
before block the scene
and now without the pressure of the of
the crew looming make decisions about
camera placements and things like that
this was the opposite this was you know
this is scene
seven of 14 scenes we're gonna shoot in
a day
we'll do a blocking he got two minutes
to make decisions about how you're gonna
shoot it
and then you gotta start shooting and i
was like i'm just gonna embrace like
whatever
whatever my gut instinct is in those
first two minutes
that's what's gonna be in the movie are
you in
because you're shooting in a real house
this is not a sound stage
uh and you know are you shooting with is
it one
camera shooting are you doing multi are
there any scenes you're doing multiple
cameras
one camera so at all times it was one
camera
one camera and that was both a uh
for covid just fewer people
but also i i from a style point of view
i was like i'm gonna commit
you know we're gonna rehearse the scene
i'm gonna have like two minutes to
figure out
the three shots that i'm gonna use to
tell the scene
not the six shots with two cameras might
give you you know i'm gonna
because i'm gonna be like these are the
only shots i have
you know i don't have a b camera that's
getting me extra stuff so what
what three shots do i absolutely need to
tell this scene
which i i to be honest i loved as a
filmmaker that my
uh my worst nightmare is a situation
where you're like shooting a scene and
it's like okay
master over over single single right
that's what they might teach you in like
film school
and i i love that that that we there was
never even the possibility of us doing
that i mean that
i just described five shots
i was like you know for the most part i
was like i'm gonna have to figure out
how to tell the scenes in three shots
and by the way i'm not interested in
kind of
i know the the audience watching the
movie doesn't care that we pulled this
off at 18 days they don't care that we
shot it in a pandemic they don't care
about any of that
like i i i
i'm not interested in this sort of
self-congratulatory
style of filmmaking even even tom cruise
and i when we talk about shooting movie
in outer space but like at the end of
the day
the audience isn't going to care that we
shot this in outer space
film geeks might but the audience at the
end of the day they want to be
entertained
they don't care about how the sausage is
made and so
uh and you don't get any credit for sort
of doing this in the pandemic
you know when we were uh um
you know someone someone said this to us
you know uh
at some point they're like you know
should you guys expect to get you know
you expect an audience to sort of give
you any uh
if any kind of free ride or give you any
uh
cut you any slack because you pulled us
off during the pandemic and i'm like no
i don't like that's you know i think
it's
you know for your audience uh you know
that your audience is going to care
about you know the
um mechanics of how the film got made
but you know the people just your
average person just tuning in on
hbo max they just want to be entertained
they don't care they did this in 18 days
or 20 days or 40 days and so
um we but
uh but again my films
you know nor did the audience watching
born identity care that matt damon and i
had to sneak around you know and shoot
scenes in places we didn't have permits
they didn't care about that they
they just want to be entertained by the
movie but but i i have discovered that
when i allow uh
the the peculiar
situation of each of a movie whatever
whatever the specifics of the when i
allow the specifics of the production to
infuse what i'm shooting
i'm usually pretty happy with the end
result and so i was going to embrace
that with lockdown and
not figure out how to cover a scene with
three shots because i want to like you
know
go to film schools and brag about it
it's because
i thought you know it will set lockdown
apart and it will it will be
uh i think we can make something that
will be more unique and
and therefore more enjoyable to an
audience
than if we shot it traditionally sure
i've
i've interviewed roger deakins a few
times and what always fascinates me
about
what roger tells me uh is that
he will always shoot with one camera no
matter what he's making
and he even did that um uh
i can't remember the the movie with the
bond movie that he did
uh that he shot it all with one camera
and the
producers and everyone were like you
need coverage and he's like no i don't
i'm gonna shoot it with this one camera
and that's gonna be the movie
but it's it's so fascinating to me that
there's no right answer
uh in terms of filmmaking and that's why
it's so exciting to talk to different
people about
the various ways people make a movie
and what's crazy about this business and
it's never lost to me is that
it's a business and yet
it's also an art form yep exactly
it's you're like i just it sort of never
ceases to amaze me that any movie really
gets made
well the best movies are every once in a
while films come along
that are both um really cool and
artistic
but also you know commercially viable
it's when the art form and the business
you know intersect and um it's always
magic when that happens
you know and it's uh but anyway um
so that means there was like no second
unit on lockdown did you you made every
you took every shot yeah
that's also pretty cool um uh so you
have a lot of cool cameos
in the movie a lot of big name stars
show up uh can you sort can you sort of
talk about
uh getting all these people involved was
it one of these things where it's like i
need you for an afternoon i need you for
an
hour how did it all come about yeah well
first of all we were going to be doing
all the zoom calls
in real time it's not like we shot
anne hathaway's side and then separately
shot the other person's side
like she was going to be acting against
mindy kaling
it would involve some tricky scheduling
because mindy's in la and
annie's in in london with us and you
know we got to find
you know or it was really challenging
for uh
dooley and jasmine who had
they had to start at three in the
morning la time
you know which was 11 london time
because we're doing it all in real time
but the i so the idea was first of all
to do the do this the calls for real
which believe it or not is is way faster
like way faster than if we had actually
had a built a set for those actors and
filmed them
you know with a proper film crew and i
was like i want them
even to the point where you talked about
cameras and decisions about
you know multi-cameras and you know one
of the early decisions was
you know my producer pj who's you know
kind of a techno you know he's really
into
technology and cameras was like showing
me all these different cameras that you
could hook up
to a laptop and you could zoom with it
but
you know it would be because like right
now like i'm using uh like i'm using a
little
camera clipped onto the top and pj is
like we can clip or
we can use a red camera you know and
there's a way to use this interface and
it can feed a signal through the usb
into the laptop
and i was like no i think we should use
the camera that's built into the laptop
we should use if someone's using a phone
we should use the camera built into the
phone
like that should be part of the style of
the movie
and so once we sort of made that
decision um
it meant that like i didn't actually
need to send anyone
to someone's home i didn't need to send
a crew or anything
we ultimately decided we would send a
sound person to everyone who appears on
zoom
we'd send therefore so we have one
person who was sort of
connected to our crew who if the person
didn't know how to use their computer if
the internet went down there'd be
somebody there that we could
who was on our team um and and but from
a safety point of view it means we're
only sending one human being
into someone else's home um because a
covet
you know again like i was sort of
excited by the fact that
the safest way to make a film during the
pandemic
was to leave people in their own homes
whenever possible
and have no actual contact with them
so and and to not mix and match people
so
uh with um anne hathaway's boss in the
film
was scripted to have a teenage son
i started thinking like who do i know
what actors do i know who have teenage
sons or daughters
because i don't want you know your
normal way of making a movie where you
would cast an actor and then you'd cast
a team
you know you cast the boss and you cast
a teenager and you put them together
and i was like no they're we need to
actually
for safety reasons we need to cast a a
father-son father-daughter combo
and so i thought about who who i knew
had teenage children and
i knew i know ben stiller and and his
son quinn and i
i called ben up and i was like you know
take us so you know you know i need you
like for a day
less than a day like half a day you and
quinn
you know are you guys into doing this
you'd be at home
which by the way is where they were
because everyone's locked out
it was like you don't have to leave your
home um
well uh and then um
so a few days before we shot ben
toured me around his house you know we
settled where he would be where the
camera would be
you know literally just like doing this
um and then he he took my uh
costume designer into his closet with it
with facetime and showed you know we
picked his wardrobe that way and um
and then all we did was send a uh a
sound person over on the day of the
shoot
so who made those signs maybe this is
telegraph but you know the person who
was dealing with this
said i don't know
or maybe ben's assistant sure
we were just like we need someone and we
need you know we're like we need signs
we need them to be this size you know
again we're like we don't have any
interaction with you because it covered
so like
but that was part of the fun and
adventure of making this film and and
steven merchant you know he he made that
whole set
and and cut out those arrows for himself
and and um
uh picked out his wardrobe um
you know we had people sort of all over
the world uh
you know that i would zoom or facetime
with and you know we'd set up the shots
and the scenes and
and again because the script was 180
pages you know i had to tell each and
every one of them i was like let's just
go through this once
and they would like run the scene with
me and they would put all these dramatic
pauses and i'd be like
here's the deal script's 180 pages
like you got to just say the dialogue as
fast as you can
it's so it's so interesting notes that
they're not used to hearing
so i'm curious about this so you you
call ben
ben says yeah that sounds awesome my son
and i are going to do it
when he agrees how tricky is it with
like
contracts with like agents and everybody
because obviously that can
go many different ways is it one of
these things where
it's a lot easier because everyone knows
that this is not some
big budget movie that like everyone's
making this at a very low cost
how does it go on behind the scenes once
like a friend of yours agrees
that you know they want to do it
um because we sort of came up with the
same rate we're going to give
anyone who appears in a cameo so we're
like this is just what we have
and because uh um
steve knight and i were gonna be you
know giving a big portion of what we
make on the film to
uh steve's case the nhs in my case to
hospitals in new york
um it uh
you know so i think you know it was
i i don't i'm like it would surprise me
if ben you know takes whatever he makes
in this film and he gives it to
you know a medical charity anyhow like
it was it was the film was sort of
happening in that
kind of context of um
we're all we're all just embarking on
this adventure together
and and nobody's trying to get rich and
it's it's a it's it's just a
it's a and we think that this film could
could could really um
is really really has a place in the
world
you know that that that there's
it's not like you're approaching ben and
you're like here's a superhero thing
said in the marvel cinematic universe
we're like here's a movie that said in
our universe today
there's nothing else like that that's
going to touch people and speak to them
in with an honest voice that people
can relate to who are going through this
pandemic
and and give them an escape at the same
time
so it it the aspirations for the film
were sort of lofty enough that it was
the there was nobody was going to be
doing this film for the money
um completely yeah um
i know i got to go with you uh but i
just want to ask whose idea was it to
have
chewed tell making bread during the
credits
again it's it's it was one of these
things
where chewie tell
just mentioned offhand
uh he was like
wouldn't it be fun if like maybe in the
credits i was making bread
he just met it was like like just
just mentioned it like off the cuff
comment like you know not expecting to
go anywhere
and the next day i showed up with the
supplies to make bread
and i was like do you mind staying after
rap i'm gonna film you making bread
i think it's a great he was like what i
just i didn't really mean that when i
said that i was like well
and actually um
my because i also we didn't want to take
the time because it actually takes some
time to actually finish making the bread
um during the shoot day because we were
shooting in a real
house my two producers
pj and allison made bread themselves
so i would have something for him to
pull out of the oven at the end
it was such a tight-knit family making
this film or then competing over who
made a better loaf of bread and
yeah in a similar way you know anne
hathaway
uh the only i didn't give any script
notes to steve i said we're shooting
your first draft
that's gonna be part of the style of
this film there's gonna be a rawness to
this
because it's not gonna be overworked
right films go through this development
process and suddenly can start to feel
like a committee and i was like
i want this to really have that that
really pure singular voice
it's like everyone's doing their job
steve you're writing the script
i'm going to shoot your script i'm
directing the film like
the producers are producing it
everyone's just doing their exact job
there's no like co-mingling
and the only thing is that the only note
i gave him is i asked him if he would
write an epilogue when he finished the
script
as though the script weren't long enough
i was like i really would like to see i
i wanna i wanna be back at the house
with them
and he wrote the epilogue you know while
we're in the middle of shooting
and suddenly was like okay what's annie
going to wear during the epilogue
because we had such a specific look for
her
like a formal top and then pajamas on
the bottom but that didn't make sense
for the epilogue that he wrote and
uh annie said uh it's similar to the
bread thing and he's like well
what about tie-dye you know because
everyone was tie-dying during the
pandemic like it would be wouldn't be
fun if i was wearing some tie-dye thing
at the end and i said
i love that idea uh where do we get
tie-dye turns out in london in in
october you cannot buy
tie-dye it's just not it's a spring
thing whatever it doesn't
and i was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna i'll go
tie it out your shirt for you
um i just asked the costume designer to
give me some some white shirts that fit
annie
and i brought it home and because of the
pandemic i was living with my producer
pj and his wife and his toddler daughter
so that we were in a pod and i went in
his backyard on a day off and started
tie-dying these shirts for annie and
then pj was like well i'll try that too
and and
rose's wife joined and so we made a
bunch of shirts
and then similar to the bread it was a
bake off you know we we gave
all the shirts to annie and and um and
obviously i'm only telling the story
because she chose my shirt
that's a that's a really good story and
a good way to end the interview um
first of all i just want to say i know i
really blew through the time limit we
had and i just said [ __ ] it because i
wanted to keep talking to you and i'm
sorry if
you're late to another meeting or
whatever you need to do
um but really i so enjoyed this movie
no i recognize that yeah thank you you
know considering the circumstances
involved it just doesn't make any sense
you know it's
it's one of those you know what i mean
yeah thank you